Hey
well I'm understaffed Kritika I remember
it so you don't have to and welcome to
sequel month the sequel so those who
don't recall there was a theme month
called sequel month why I looked over
all the sequel to awful films I've
already reviewed well you know what I
want some goodness before I start to
shitstorm
you see sequels have gotten a reputation
as always being inferior to the original
and in many respects they're right but
that doesn't mean there aren't some
amazing ones out there
there are people who saw part 2 3 or 4
not only as a way to make more money but
as a chance to continue with story
provide a brand new angle or even outdo
what the original did to win over so
many people there's plenty of them to
look at and they deserve to be
acknowledged as much as possible
and we're going to look at the top 11 of
them here today why top 11 because by
god I knew as many of these as possible
these are the top 11 greatest movie
sequel
[Music]
number 11 Mad Max fury road the Mad Max
movies are known for having some kickass
mind-blowing sequels the first film
started off as a low-budget seemingly
exploitation style revenge flick but as
they kept moving on they turned it to a
pocke lipstick bloodbath each one
getting stranger and more action-packed
well the crowning achievement by many is
yuri road which like the other Mad Max
film can be seen as a continuation a
standalone film a little bit about all
the movies has a mix of past themes
imagery and ideas even some of the
actors come back in different roles this
takes the exact same thing and cranked
it up to a million this is by far the
biggest Mad Max movie with the best I
can decrease Dunst and visual
storytelling so much of the narrative is
done just through the characters
expressions and actions which one you
think about is very difficult to do but
you just look at any of these people
whether they be side characters or main
players and you immediately know their
backstory I've done the whole review on
this film so you can check that out if
you want more detail but needless to say
it's booked totally different from where
the film started out but also a perfect
fit for where they naturally and even
unnaturally seemed to be going over to
film was enough food
you
number ten rocki rocki films also have a
fascinating legacy when the first film
came out it starts basically a nobody
who wanted to prove his worth once he
did his success exploded much like the
main character and each movie as well as
his career got a little bigger and a
little goofier until age finally started
to set in and things slowed down making
room for the real world yeah it's
interesting how much art imitates real
life isn't it these films in the
strangest of ways are kind of like
personal portraits but the one that
shocked people the Mosin how good it was
was rocking to the crystal ones this
picture in 1977 so the idea of doing a
follow-up almost seemed silly why table
what already won one of the biggest
awards there is in many respects it
should have even worked with a plot that
almost seem repetitive of the original
but there's just enough new problems to
get in the way to still make it
interesting
little things that you wouldn't even
think of Rocky thinks his life will
change with endorsements but he has no
charisma with the camera he thinks
things will get better with more fights
but his eye seems too damaged to do so
what should have been a fairy tale
ending from the last film has a reality
that's all too good a nickel and diming
one's dignity on paper you would think
it wouldn't work but it pulls out a
strong emotional heartbreaking but also
inspiring sequel that confirmed that
both Stallone and rocky were not just
when they wondered even after seeing the
same story before they once again got us
to cheer for the right person for the
right reason
[Music]
number nine
Star Trek to the Wrath of Khan the
interesting thing about this one is it's
coming up the heels of a movie that
while financially ahead didn't get much
praise from audiences and critics
well not awful by any means the still
seem more concerned with being 2001
rather than Star Trek the sequel was a
way of seeing it the financial hit of
the last one was a fluke or a Star Trek
actually had staying power
it pulled off what many consider to be
the best Star Trek it incorporated both
the ideas of Star Trek and the emotions
of Star Trek
focusing on revenge strategy life death
just about anything that makes a grand
epic and keep in mind this is that time
with Star Trek but still Sofia with this
everything from the music to the effect
to the perfectly over-the-top acting
made this a marvel that really would
have gone over fine if it just played as
an extensive episode but they didn't
just do that they put all their talent
and effort into it making it one hell of
a suspenseful action-packed funny
depressing uplifting all-encompassing
film it retreaded what made Star Trek's
are great but also what were no trick
film had gone before and it still holds
up even to this day
number 8 2 way story to the first Toy
Story was already something of a risk
Disney was not doing especially well at
the time and the idea of the first CG
movie being this bright colorful
kid-friendly flick did not seem like a
good idea but thanks to great writing in
great direction now every animated film
is trying to be Toy Story but then a
bug's life soon followed and was very
rushed through the Katzenberg leaving
Disney saying he was taking the bug idea
with him so - ant movies came out that
year and while they boasted good neither
was seeing a Toy Story so there's a big
fear that maybe Pixar was a one-trick
pony with Toy Story just a lucky fluke
was there possibly no future for them
why don't 2032 was the chance for them
to redeem themselves and by god that's
exactly what they did they pushed the
technology further the comedy further
and most of all the story further it
introduced brand new characters with
brand new problems and dilemmas nothing
seen redone it felt like the exact
perfect direction the story should go
causing audiences to laugh and applaud
all the way through some would debate
Toy Story 3 is a better sequel but
here's the thing whatever you think of
that film there was no risk that it
would be a bad movie Pixar already
established itself with hit after hit
Toy Story 2 on the other hand was not
only a better film but it showed that
Pixar was there to stay and that they
had a lot more talent and creativity to
bring there was something to be lost if
it didn't do well while Toy Story 3 was
a great goodbye sort of Toy Story 2 is
what showed there was plenty of staying
power with this adventure comedy and
surprising amount of emotion for being
once again they know exactly how to go
to infinity and beyond
[Music]
number seven alien a sequel so good that
they have the greatest sequel title of
all time we already know what one alien
can do so simply making it plural is
beyond terrifying and it's not just one
but hundreds of aliens that attack while
also adding a new twist with there being
a queen alien some of badass bitch in
the galaxy taking more of an action
rather than a whore around alien still
brought the intensity as well as long
lasting feeds the ideas of trust family
and bonding for survival are all
explored in adult yet still exciting
ways to two mothers duking it out people
just believing others and new
connections that have to be established
all for the goal of figuring the best
way to get through the worst nature as
often all of these characters are
memorable they're not just people you're
waiting for to die you want them to get
through and feel pretty damned bummed
when someone doesn't we like them and
don't want to see them go and the true
horror film is supposed to be the
effects are amazing the action perfectly
paced the emotional moments legitimately
effective it took one of the best horror
films of the past few decades and
elevated it to a whole new level
[Music]
Terminator 2 Judgment Day from one James
Cameron think we'll do another James
Cameron sequel Terminator took the idea
of the killer Austrian robot that was
corny but so cool to a whole new
dimension of action stunts and effects
making what many consider to be the best
action film of all time well many of us
are used to seeing Arnold as a good guy
now keep in mind the sequel wasn't
advertised like that in fact a lot of it
was kept in secret you just saw him
looking menacing with the red eye and
that was it so everyone thought both of
it was just going to be Robert Patrick
as the hero and Schwarzenegger once
again is the villain what is awesome
surprised to discover the character we
like watching most in the first film is
now the one we're rooting for in the
sequel well it certainly had its repeat
moments for fanservice it still never
feels like it's just a retelling it
feels like real shit is at stake real
people have evolved and realize they're
being put on the line because a lot of
these stuns were actually putting lives
on the line as groundbreaking as the CG
was in this movie people forget whenever
something was destroyed it was really
destroyed in front of the camera it was
only when something was repairing itself
that the computers came in so this was a
perfect mix of both practical and
computer effects because of this we can
still watch this film and be blown away
and not just say oh that computer that
computer they didn't really do any of
that know so much as it was really there
we get to say wow they really crashed
that truck off a cliff they really flew
that copter over a bridge they really
blew up a metal Robert Patrick it's
incredible it's an amazing spectacle to
say the least and we're all happy to
tell that Arnold came back
[Music]
number five the Dark Knight Batman has
had an interesting history to say
believed we're all the ups and downs and
all didn't seem like there were much
possibilities and film for him anymore
Batman Begins was really good but it
wasn't breaking any box-office records
and it still fell flat when it came to
the action and villain its sequel not
only fixed that but took comic book
movies to a whole new level when comic
films were still kind of seen as kid
stuff
Dark Knight won over everybody with its
adult imagery adult ideas adult acting
such as you in effect comic mostly adult
acting and adult intensity this is the
film that wants so many famous life so
many incredible action scene so many
suspenseful moments it was the first
time since the 1989 Batman that people
were saying oh my god that was an
amazingly badass Batman movie he pulled
no punches and went all-out with how
dark it could go but it also carried
many themes of duality sacrifice and
anarchy this show not only could comic
book movies be big bucks but it could be
gigantic box and it didn't have to talk
down to people or make it too
kid-friendly it could represent the
original dark material the way it was
meant to be represented the film
borrowed from dozens of famous Batman
stories but still brilliantly managed to
stay its own thing as well its dark edge
got under people's skin so much that not
only was this the first comic film to
receive a Best Actor Academy Award but
it was also the further war to be given
after the actor passed away it knocked
down all barriers and says there's
something to these comic book stories
you just have to use the right people
who understand it it said proudly and
confidently why these movies should be
so serious
[Music]
you
number four Lord of the Rings of Return
of the King some would say two towers
should get this mark as it was the first
sequel to outdo the already popular
Fellowship of the Ring this movie broke
on the record please hundreds of critics
win over most audiences and even swept
the Academy Awards being the first
fantasy film to win Best Picture like
Dark Knight
this show does genre that was seen more
as kid stuff could be a powerful force
to be reckoned with where the first two
films are also very good everyone seems
to have their own personal problems with
them ranging from tiny to major but this
film was so gigantic that even the
problems they had are quickly forgotten
because they were just sucked into the
size and scope of what we were watching
all the characters all the storylines
everything that had been built up in
hours and hours of entertainment
suddenly had to be wrapped up and it
went out with a huge bang the only major
problem people seem to have is that the
ending goes on forever which is a legit
criticism we could drag and sometimes
they're even a little uncomfortable yeah
but when you factor in the amount of
characters these movies had and how long
they were it does kind of make sense
that it would be a little long it's like
trying to calm down after so much
intensity was thrown in your face in
many respects it was kind of a good
decompressor in the grand scheme of
things it's not really that big a
problem it was quickly forgotten when
they look back at the rest of the film
when people point to epics now they
usually either go to the biblical film
or Lord of the Rings what was seen as
box-office poison and unfilmable by many
fans was now one of the biggest epics of
all time and the Best Picture winner of
2004 when it's often said sequel to
never win this one definitely went out
on top
[Music]
number three Bride of Frankenstein
Frankenstein is arguably one of the most
famous stories of all time because it's
in the public domain
people do version after version of it
there's literally dozens of them
nevertheless it's the original Boris
Karloff version that's still seen as the
timeless classic it scared people to
death with its timeless ideas got the
catmus beer and groundbreaking makeup
hope the idea of doing a sequel seemed
fitting but come on
nobody could top the original classic
well not only is the sequel as good as
the first but it's seen by many to be
even better
it takes the ideas of creating life to a
new level as well as explore the
monstrous humanity and his ability to
learn sometimes even beyond his human
predecessors once again playing with the
idea of who's the real monster you think
you couldn't create something as
memorable as the original monster design
but with the bride they definitely did
nobody can forget that hairdo with the
white stripe or the hitch she lets out
like a frightened animal so not on
screen long she left a big impression
just like everything in these
Frankenstein movies do the shadows the
acting the downright depressing
storytelling it's both hopeful and
innocent but also mean-spirited and
despicable these two movies are among
some of the most referenced in any form
of media they're immediately
recognizable because they lead such an
impact on us there's a reason you see
them everywhere whether it's Halloween
or not and the genius of both these
films still shines through today in a
medium where horror sequels are usually
seen with diminishing results this is
one that definitely knew how to keep the
magic alive it dies
number two The Godfather Part two
the first Godfather film was a landmark
in motion picture history many say it's
one of the best American films ever made
it was brutal stylized but also highly
realistic all some of that nature had
never really been seen and we've not to
that degree so being able to follow up
seemed strange granted it was the same
people working on it but what else was
there to tell the movie seemed to end on
a perfect note well this one further
explored how much humanity has to be
given up for what's apparently seeing is
the greater good and how the greater
good never really seems to have a finish
line through family betrayal and
violence we see how far a person can
still go to hold on to power while also
holding on to any semblance of decency
if there's any left but on top of that
we also get the backstory of a character
that was done by one of the greatest
performances of all time who could
possibly play the younger version of the
oscar-winning Marlon Brando Robert
DeNiro of course this was the movie that
cemented him as one of the great heavy
hitters of acting seeing how a child can
come from nothing with literally
everything working against him and
trying to kill him yet can somehow
become the epitome of power at a price
this was the first sequel to win Best
Picture and the only one to win with its
previous film as well Godfather 1 also
won Best Picture at a time when
Godfather was said to be the perfect
movie that couldn't be topped Godfather
2 tried it and not only succeeded but
made what many consider one of the
greatest films ever made
it's hard enough to make something as
incredible as Godfather 1 but to do it
twice that's an amazing feat what can
you say it made us an offer we couldn't
refuse
and the number one movie sequel and
Star Wars The Empire Strikes Back now
limit I had a rough time trying to
figure out which would be number one
this or Godfather two they're both
different but also seen as the best
sequels out there they both cook America
by surprise and we're said that the idea
of making a sequel them didn't seem like
a good idea because the original was
perfect and of course they're both seen
as better than the original but here's
what pushed it over the line for me
Godfather had to only impress adults
Star Wars had to impress adults and kids
many people say oh it's easy to make
something for kids but making something
for both kids and adult and being
legitimately entertaining for both can
be very very tricky especially if it's
not a comedy think about it you're
telling a story about sci-fi wizards
you're going to get adults interested in
this well not only did they do it in
many respects they got more adult
interested in kids you could argue why
because Star Wars could have very easily
just been a retelling just finding
another big ball to destroy more comic
relief and more weird creatures to fight
but this movie didn't do that away until
the last one to do that this will not
only continue the story as opposed to
repeat it but it took it to a new darker
aggressive frightening and more adult
world yet through all of that kids still
watched it they didn't run away they
didn't say it was too scary or grown-up
they said they want to handle the rough
stuff with us even the big reveal which
I won't give away really challenges a
lot of children's perceptions of good
and evil for many it's the first time
they're playing together that maybe
things aren't always so black-and-white
in a world that seemed tailor-made for
things to be black and white one of my
favorite things to do is to watch kids
reactions when they hear that big reveal
they just can't believe it it takes them
totally by surprise but this is a good
kind of surprise a surprise that
challenges them and forces them to think
a little different hell a lot of adults
are suddenly forced to think a little
different too they didn't see that
surprise coming on top of that this was
a sequel to the highest-grossing money
maker of all time
if it just wanted to repeat itself it
could do that it would have little to no
laws but they didn't they took a huge
chance they said let's have a go darker
let's have a go more aggressive let's
really make people uncomfortable but
kids - that is a big risk that both kids
and adults are really glad that they
took this could have been the easiest
money grant but instead they decided to
go a different direction that chances
are most people didn't see coming
it's like Mark Twain used to say my
books are like water those of great
geniuses are wine but fortunately
everybody drinks water Godfather is the
wine Star Wars is the water
everybody can get it everybody can
relate to something in it and everyone
of any age can get something of value
out of it there's absolutely no denying
the force is strong with this
whether ice equals I meant well leave
them in the comments below and pray for
me this month I'm going to statue critic
and sequel month is on the way
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing Action
Aid USA action a believes that we can
bring an end to poverty and injustice by
investing in local problem solvers they
know that local people understand their
context better than we ever can they are
determined committed and motivated to
change the world around them that's why
they actively invest in powerful people
living in poverty in 45 countries around
the world problem solvers who know
what's needed to change lives within
their own community and has the power to
mobilize and inspire others they tackle
problems where they can make the most
difference connecting problem solvers
from communities around the world with
the people whose decisions affect their
daily lives this way they can understand
and claim their rights and bring out
change that lasts this is a wonderful
idea that has already done so much good
work and helped so many good places and
good people if you go to their website
or their YouTube page you can see their
constant hard work and constant
dedication to not only helping those in
need
but finding the best way for it to last
the longest check them out and see how
you too can help in a great cause
[Music]
you